is the human race under threat of
destruction this man thinks so and he
has a plan for saving it he's a renowned
scientist inventor and most famously
he's the man who came up with a
revolutionary new idea of how the earth
works this is James Lovelock and he's
just turned a hundred years old he
believes artificial intelligence or
so-called cyborgs could take control
cool the planet and allow the human
species to survive
[Music]
James Lovelock's work has changed the
way scientists look at everything from
the common cold to life on Mars he
invented a device that detected ozone
damaging CFCs in the atmosphere all
around the world a precursor to the
detection of holes in the ozone layer
James Lovelock's revolutionary insights
about the earth behaving like a living
being a single complex self-regulating
system reframe the way environmentalists
understand the earth he named the idea
after the ancient Greek goddess of Earth
Gaia
[Music]
Geyer is the name given to the system of
organisms that live on the earth and
maintain its climate suitable for life
but James Lovelock skaia
is no kindly goddess protecting
humankind from itself he argues that
humans have pushed Gaia
to its limit and whilst the earth will
eventually rebalance itself it may be
too late for the human race unless
humans start making drastic changes you
will have many options if they want to
save themselves on the planet
this is his full point plan to save
humankind by 2050 a hundred and forty
million people could be forced to
migrate within their countries because
of climate change
but why wait James Lovelock believes
land that will be made uninhabitable
should be abandoned now humans should
retreat to efficient safe
climate-controlled cities humans should
go to mega cities if they want to avoid
the worst dangers of climate change
mainly because a city is a smaller unit
to control and regulate the Cotten's of
composition of the atmosphere the soil
rather similar to the nests of
invertebrates and various kind ants
wasps bees whereas the open space of the
planet itself is huge and not easy to
handle
[Music]
according to James Lovelock
humans need to rethink the way they
power the world ditching fossil fuels
and switching not just to renewable but
to nuclear power if we want to avoid
damaging the planet by our way of life
do not burn fuel unnecessarily we should
be using nuclear power now as our main
source of energy fears around nuclear
energy have been compounded by disasters
like Chernobyl in Fukushima but for
James Lovelock these fears remain
misplaced the extraordinary thing is it
is the safest way of producing
electricity the desperate for in power
stations that use nuclear is way way way
below that in any of the other forms
including renewables
[Music]
global warming may be the biggest threat
facing humanity attempts to cut carbon
emissions are too small to reduce carbon
dioxide levels James Lovelock thinks
climate controlling technology called
geoengineering could be the answer I
rather like tellers idea the inventor of
the hydrogen bond which is the sunshade
it's the kind of mesh screen that goes
out into a heliocentric orbit around the
Sun and shields the earth to the Sun a
percent of the sun's radiation but
there's another way to build a sunshade
inside the Earth's atmosphere in 1991 a
volcanic eruption in the Philippines had
a profound effect on the world the gas
cloud it produced reached the
stratosphere cooling the world by as
much as not 0.5 degrees Celsius for four
years the simplest thing was really to
mimic volcanoes and put sulfur gases
into the stratosphere to form a haze
that blocks off sunshine that would
prevent overheating from the Sun James
Lovelock boldest prescription emerges
from his belief that the earth is on the
verge of a new era one where the
dominant form of life is artificial
I'm not concerned just with evolution of
lumps of flesh that can move around and
do things managed by a somewhat
primitive intelligence no I think it's
the evolution of intelligence
that is the key driver in the Darwinian
process he believes artificial
intelligence cyborgs will move beyond
human control generating intelligences
far greater than our own they will be
far more capable than humans of tackling
climate change I would hope that cyborgs
that do a much better job of protecting
the planet than humans have done because
they can think 10,000 sounds faster if
they work strenuously hard to keep the
temperature of the planet at a safe and
desirable point there it would benefit
them and enormously benefit us Homo
sapiens has been the dominant species on
earth for tens of thousands of years if
the human race is to survive James
Lovelock believes the key is for it to
surrender its position of privilege and
give way to more intelligent life we
might think that sideburns would be very
bored with humans and wouldn't want to
watch them at all because they're so
boring but then I would say but you go
to cube garden sent you to watch the
plants grow but of course there are
things that even a I would struggle to
control do I think humans can be saved
from the numerous threats that exist in
the cosmos I don't know I hope so
you